a medida que se acerca la segunda vuelta
en Brasil el tribunal electoral comienza
a preparar las urnas electrónicas con la
intención de mejorar y agilizar la
votación respecto al primer turno
muchos votantes se han quejado de la
lentitud de algunas sesiones de votación
por lo que el tribunal electoral
corregirá ese problema
y es que a pesar de ser una herramienta
más para ejercer el derecho a voto en
Brasil este año las urnas electrónicas
son un foco de atención ya que el
presidente de ultraderecha Yair
bolsonaro se ha encargado de sembrar
dudas respecto a la fiabilidad del
sistema en 2018 ya sostuvo que no había
ganado en primera vuelta por fraude
así estoy seguro de que si este problema
no hubiera ocurrido si hubiera confianza
en el sistema electrónico ya tendríamos
el nombre del próximo presidente de
Brasil
y cuando todavía faltaba un año para las
elecciones en 2021 volvió a arremeter
contra su fiabilidad motiva incluso
protestas en contra del voto electrónico
[Aplausos]
no puedo participar en una farsa como
esa patrocinada por el presidente del
tribunal electoral superior
algo que algunos expertos han señalado
como una estrategia para intentar
aferrarse al poder en caso de perder el
30 de octubre Y es que esta no es la
única actitud autoritaria del mandatario
en los últimos meses también lanzó una
amenaza velada al tribunal supremo dos
supremos el tribunal supremo puede
seguir pensando que puede hacer lo que
quiera pollo
no voy a vivir como una rata
debe haber una reacción
bolsonaro antiguo comandante militar
dijo que las fuerzas armadas no se
limitarán a dar el visto bueno al
proceso electoral este año algo que ha
puesto al sistema judicial en alerta